خطبه خطيره الى الوراء يحذر الاطباء الى
الماسك من خطها في تويتر التنبيه واطلق
اثر تراجع شركه تويتر بعد ان اصبحت في
عصمه مالكها الجديد الملياردير الى الماسك
عن سياسه معالجه المعلومات المطله عن
فيروس كورونا قبل نشرها على المنصه ومع
اعلان تويتر لقرارها المفاجئ والذي ياتي
ضمن سلسله من القرارات التي وصفت بالجدليه
لماسك والتي يبدو ان جعبه الرجل مملوءه
بها اثيرا قلقوا مسؤولي الصحه في العالم
خاصه وان الفيروس باقي ويتمدد بل ويتسبب
بالموت احيانا ما قد يعني ان قرار ماسك
زاد مخاوف الخبراء من انتشار المرض بشكل
اوسع لتكبر احتمالات الوفيات بين المصابين
وبالعوده عامين الى الوراء
كانت الاشادات بالموقع الابرز في عالم
التواصل الاجتماعي تتكرر في كل مره يتصدى
للمعلومات المضله ويرفض نشرها في ذلك
الوقت اوقفت تويتر اكثر من 11,000 حساب
وازاله اكثر من مئه الف جزء من المحتوى
الانتهاكها السياسه بعض تلك الحسابات كانت
تمتلكها شخصيات سياسيه
ومن اشهر الحسابات التي اغلقت كانت لعضوه
الحزب الجمهوري الامريكي ماروتشري اقتل
رجلين التي تم تعليق حسابها الشخصي في ذلك
الوقت لتشكيكها في فعاليه لقاحات فيروس
كرونو
حسابها الاسبوع الماضي حنان المصري العربي